let's just imagine for a moment okay
let's imagine we be through a paper okay
this was question one we did it this was
the answer all of us routes and then
we've got our five minutes of the end
and we come back to this and then so you
think okay wait something is gone wrong
we want to fix this what should we do
can someone give me some advice yeah you
know how when you get the game you have
to it okay alright so the first part
that we do this is edition right as you
can see in the first slide the
denominator here has changed yes is
three and five before it's 15 now it
should be 15 by the way what why 1550 is
a good number free transfer it's the
it's the lowest common multiple right I
can fit threes into this number and I
can few fires into this number so
that'll give me a common denominator
that's good okay but if the denominator
changes then what do these things up top
cornea the numerators also must change
okay so for this exon 3 to become not
excellent treatment something on 15 what
if i multiplied that's right i multiply
the top and bottom by 5 so this is going
to become 5x in much the same way to
turn this guy into something on 15 what
did I x 33 certain to X becomes 6x okay
so now we've got a we've identified the
problem that's just as hard as doing a
problem right identify what you want to
say again okay so i'm not i'm not
finished in here although i've done so
far is i've converted these two factions
in two different forms not simple forms
but forms that can talk to each other
yeah now they both going to be on 15 yes
that's right so these two are equal to 7
i'm now going to carry all with Gary's
like you but just corrected a little bit
so these numbers should be five and six
shouldn't they you see where they come
from five
and six okay now i know that numbers are
pyro will fix them in a second but just
carry on his working what's Gary done
from this line to this line what's he
done oh no one we can pick awake this
one I should point out I should put this
line itself is actually doing two things
it's doing this and then it's doing this
right so let's take the one step at a
time that top thing to feel my circle
what did he do we could all work this
out okay good so he's like he had X into
X right yeah so they became 3x and then
went this topic of rock he's multiply
through by 15 has me because I don't
want 15 of the denominator I want to get
it out of the way and we have two x 52
we have 15 there as well okay he
multiplied across black 15 that gave a
105 and in one of these bad why do you
do this very good okay so now we know
what you did let's do it with the right
numbers this shouldn't be three should
actually be 11 all right is that 105
correct yeah it is right because it's
still seven times 15 thumbs up but now
instead of dividing by 3
I'd buy by 11 cuz that's the number i'm
trying to get rid of okay so it looks to
me like i don't think i don't think
that's going to be anything nicer than I
Drive yeah I'm just gonna leave it okay
I suppose I could but if i wanted to i
could write that as 9 and 6 cyl Evans
okay but I don't think I owe those is
it's not like I told you please give you
a mix d rule or a proper fashion they're
both one okay I can have a look at this
one what do you think happy you're happy
seems I understood it authors of the
answer it looks vaguely correct okay
that last step 201 separate time um this
is algebra lightness numbers and then
there's protocol so I'm going to deal
with them one at a time 1218 what's
turned them into two and three that's
nice I've divided by x 6 this is
actually what I do did here but in
Reverse yeah here I had nice simple
honest but I wanted to make them bigger
so these could work together but here i
have big numbers and i want to make them
smaller so we divided through by six by
six to 18 to my name I six is three
thumbs up no one yes it looks right okay
having done with the numbers I would do
with the pretty rules now I'm just going
to go through in order I've conveniently
given them to you in matching order so
you're saying x cubed that's actually an
abbreviation what's in abbreviations for
x 20 x times x 3 x that's why there's a
three day so if there's x times X times
X up here and a single X down the bottom
then one payroll cats all right which
leaves you with two x's at the top cool
so X square that's x times X you can
keep going through you can see there's 2
a's up here a times a and there's five
of the myth so when you do you cancel
you get on the bottom three left and up
here does this check out yes okay so
that looks good how many see you your
figures how did you know for
because this just born okay there are
there are three zeros right these guys
and they don't count they're not
significant why aren't they significant
whereas this sky you are telling me yes
ha ok so these numbers here right these
could have come from approximating right
like i did some count and then someone
told me round to the nearest a thousand
so that's where the zeros came from but
this number cannot come from rounding
right this is not on the end of the
number it's right there nestled in the
middle so it must have come by me
actually counting up I was at seven what
is this this is a million something so I
was a seven billion 909 thousand dollar
and then I ticked over and got 28
million etc and I kept on counting right
so all these numbers are significant
because I counted them or bheja them in
some way whereas those criminal
proximate